The city should be a space of
coexistence where you have to have
everything you want at hand. Now we talk
about the 15-minute city
[Music]
We made our own project for Ponteve
and Ponteve. It was a city Well, at
that time it had 73 thousand inhabitants
Now we have 84 who grew up throughout the
municipality but mostly in the
center of the city and in a city that was
uninhabitable this was a real
car warehouse with
polluted noise where there was no
public space where people had no
autonomy to occupy public space
[  Music]
for that we did two or three things one
eliminated unnecessary traffic so
that the city works two are the
passing traffic we had a study that
said that 30% of the cars that
crossed the city did not stop in the
city then there were the
agitation traffic, which is the one that once there
is no longer any parking space on the surface, they
spend their time driving around to see if
someone leaves,
we go from 30% allocated to
public space in the city and 70% allocated
to motor traffic  On the contrary, 70% for
people and 30% for the traffic
necessary for the city to function.
What it causes, it causes less
pollution, less noise, less traffic jams,
which after 24 years we show that there
are very few and are perfectly
compatible with a high quality of life
and  especially with a great
economic activity and they make the city more
attractive, it won people over was the space
that was freed from cars and was improved
and illuminated and filled with
activities etc. since it was filled with
people since 2011 without a single
died due to being hit by a car in the city
because this was previously a street that had
parking in a row, parking in
line, some one meter narrow sidewalks
and then cars parked in double rows
in triple rows. This street was not absolutely
unlivable, not and what
we transformed it into is a  space with a
single platform and coexistence and that
really improved a lot in every
way. I know many people who
come to live in Puertobeddra because
they have children and prefer a city with
that quality of life than not living in another
city, especially the people who can
afford the luxury of teleworking, there
are even foreign people from Merija,
people from England, French, many
live here and work but choose to
contain it for their quality of life
[Music]
when we talk about Recovering
public space for people, we are talking about
democracy, we are talking about
equality, we are talking  Of rights, we
are talking about making a
feminist design of public space because
women are the ones who use space the most.
We have to fight for
quality of life to avoid
climate change to improve people's autonomy
to achieve democracy in
public space.  for
social cohesion for all this there may be
opposition I say no but
citizens are smarter than
some politicians think and they understand
perfectly when you are acting
in favor of the general interest or you are
acting defending
particular and private interests which
are normally always  of them. I think that
mostly it is because people
resist changes and are afraid that
this change means they can lose
when you leave your house you need to
find a public space that is a
continuity of your own home that is
quiet that is safe that is
pleasant  that is attractive and has
an urban design that can be easily read
[Music]